hey guys this is inca and in this video
i will only be eating disney princess
foods for 24 hours
you guys have seen me do a lot of
cooking challenges so far obviously a
lot of colored food ones which i'm still
going to be making and i've also done
videos where i try to recreate a dish
from a specific game and as someone who
loves disney and especially disney
princesses
i thought it would be fun to challenge
myself to only make
and eat disney princess meals for
24 hours i think it's really cool that a
lot of these disney princesses
have different cultural backgrounds that
also means that today
i will be making a variety of dishes
from all across the world
and that's pretty exciting i'm looking
at making at least three meals and one
dessert
so i'm gonna be crazy busy in the
kitchen today it's going to be a
fun-filled journey or should i say
a magical adventure all right let's do
this good morning
it is now time for breakfast the most
important meal of the day
for this meal i have decided to go with
the
bacon and egg porridge congee
from mulan my favorite disney princess
for those of you who remember
the one that has that like cute little
smiley face on top this is the porridge
that mushu made mulan
on her first day of training to kind of
cheer her up and encourage her
so i figured this is kind of the perfect
way to start off
today i'm not entirely sure why there's
bacon i feel like regular pork belly
is a little more mainstream in chinese
culture but regardless
i am going to make my dish as similar as
the one
mulan had all right let's get started
and hope i bring honor to us all
ingredients wise we only have a few
things we need our eggy eyes
and then our bacon smile and
i have a cup of rice i grew up eating
congee a lot and my mom used to put like
sliced ginger pieces
into my congee both for flavor and
because she said it was good for me and
i also like to flavor it with a little
bit of salt
and some white pepper i'm also going to
be using my trusty rice cooker
to cook the porridge for me since it has
a porridge setting and that can save me
some time first things first
gotta wash the rice
drop a little bit of ginger in there
close it porridge option
and while the kanji is cooking i'm gonna
get started on frying up the eggs and
the bacon
also making some chinese tea
[Music]
exciting news my kanji is finally done
ta-da
just add a sprinkle of that white pepper
powder a tiny bit of salt
give it a good mix and porridge is
done i have my bacon and i have my two
eggs
so all this left at this point is just
to plate everything up
and make sure that my smiley face
actually looks like a smiley face
it looks a little cross-eyed for sure
but that's kind of what the eyes look
like in the movie
and my little bacon strip here the color
looks
pretty on point so i'm very very happy
and
also here i have my tea that i made
earlier
i had to have tea with this meal because
remember when mulan went to meet like
the matchmaker i remember one of the
evaluations was
her pouring tea and i just remember that
scene so vividly
and also tea just goes really well with
chinese breakfast and kanji
i'm actually really really happy with
how this meal turned out smells really
comforting growing up my mom would
usually make kanji for me when i'm sick
so this is just very nostalgic and
super cute i'm gonna take a bite oh my
little smiley faces
is destroyed it's warm it's comforting i
love the little bits of ginger in there
it just gives it a little more flavor
also this is a big bowl of congee it's a
very very
filling one which is probably
appropriate because
mulan was having this before she had to
do her training so she needed um
sustenance now take a sip of my tea
this is honestly one of the best ways to
start off your days because it's like
fills you up with warmth it's comforting
you know you're not
going to be hungry for a while i love it
and i'm sure mulan appreciated this meal
as well going to actually sit down now
and slowly enjoy this meal before i get
started on lunch
i finally finished breakfast and i am
super super full
but the next meal i want to make takes a
lot of cooking time
so i'm going to get started right away
back to the kitchen it is
so for lunch i'm going to be making
princess tiana's
gumbo from the princess and the frog
princess tiana is obviously an amazing
chef
all the food in that film just looked so
incredible
and i remember that scene where she was
making gumbo with her dad you know
she was just like a little kid and she
was stirring this huge pot of gumball
and her dad had that first bite
and it just like blew his mind princess
tiana grew up in new orleans
which is one of my favorite places to be
amazing music
amazing flavors and gumbo is one of
their most
popular dishes so i'm excited to try and
make it today and hopefully make tiana
proud
i did quite a bit of research and these
are the ingredients i'll be using
chicken thighs some andouille sausages
then i have some okra some chicken stock
red bell pepper celery garlic and onion
i'm putting shrimp in because i remember
tiana putting some in her so that's why
i'm gonna dress mine up with
some of these eventually some bay leaf
and
this really special spice blend these
two spice blends are ones that i bought
when i
went to new orleans a while back and i'm
very very excited to use it because they
just smell
so good this is going to be a very very
hearty stew
and it's going to take a lot of time but
you know how tiana always just looks
like she's having so much time enjoying
herself in the kitchen
singing and dancing so i am hoping to
channel that energy today
and make this gumbo first thing i'm
going to do
is fry my chicken thighs season them of
course with some salt and pepper
and a little bit of this spice blend and
in the meantime
i'm going to chop up my vegetables also
my sausages
chicken is done i've set it to a side
now to make our roux
which is what's going to make our gumble
slightly thicker and also give it that
signature smoky flavor
again this stuff will take quite a bit
of time i'm talking 30 to 40 minutes but
i'm just going to put on some music
and jam out okay the roux is pretty much
done
it is this dark like milk chocolate
color
it smells really smoky but not burnt so
that's a good sign so now i can throw in
my vegetables
and just cook that a little bit until
tender and then i'm just deglazing it
before i add in my chicken stock
lots of flavor going on in here chicken
stock is in now i'm also throwing in
some thyme
also my sausages and a bit of okra so at
this point everything that needs to be
in
is already in the next thing to do is
basically let this simmer for at least
three hours so yeah quite a bit of time
that just means
i can do some work now and then i can
check on it
every once in a while make sure it
doesn't stick and then we'll add the
shrimp in
at the very end it smells so good in
here right now
even before i'm tasting it i can already
smell all those flavors we put in
this consistency looks about right this
smell
is just incredible so far it does look
like the one that tiana made so i
am very very excited about this also the
kind of smell that already makes you
kind of salivate so yeah this is done i
am going to put this in a bowl and serve
it up
all right and here is my final product
this is what my gumbo looks like i put a
little bit of rice in the middle
that's how they usually serve it i also
put some green onions on the very top
color looks about right i also grabbed
my tabasco because tiana in the movie
adds a dash of this to her final plate
and her dad loved it so i figured
i would do that too i also made a quick
cup of iced coffee to go with it i wish
i had beignets for now i am
so ready to try this gumbo it just
smells so good a little bit of
everything
so i did have gumbo a few times when i
was in louisiana and
this does remind me of it there's so
much flavor in here because of
all the stuff we put in right so you end
up with this like spicy
savory and very very rich stew i'm gonna
add a little bit of tabasco
it all goes together so well oh my god
wow you know how in the film when people
first have tiana's cooking their faces
just like
light up that's how i feel right now
can't stop eating this
i am not eating like a disney princess
i'm just like stuffing my face
a disney princess who can make this
incredible
all right i will not subject you guys to
watching me wolf down the rest of this
even though it took a lot of time i'm
really glad i had the opportunity
to actually make this and taste this at
home it is definitely spicy though
i'm like um sweating all right i am now
going to eat this off screen and then
we're going to be back
to get started on dinner which is going
to be
a feast as if i haven't been feasting
all day already
okay that was a super satisfying meal
but my work
is far from done because for dinner i'm
planning on
making a meal from beauty and the beast
so remember when belle first gets to the
castle
and they welcome her with this whole
spread of food that's also the part
where lumiere sings be our guest which
is one of my favorite songs there's this
one part where the chorus goes
before goo cheese souffle and you see
like the little trays of food dancing on
the table
that's what i'm gonna do the beef ragu
and a cheese souffle it's a little
ambitious i know
and because i do not have the help of
animated objects
i am going to start prepping fairly
early so i'm going to start it with our
beef ragu these are the base ingredients
i have some beef
onion garlic tomato paste here diced
tomatoes
as well as some aromatics i'm going to
add some more spices along the way as
well as some wine but the main thing
here is that the sauce needs to cook for
a long time
that's why i am starting so early the
first thing i'm going to do
is to brown my beef season it a little
bit
i'm going to let it do its thing while i
cut up the vegetables
adding some tomato paste and deglaze
this with
some wine i know i just ate but it's so
hard to not want to eat again i have
no idea how belle resisted like if i was
belle i'd just camp out right there i
had some frozen beef stock so i put that
in there as well
and i'm gonna add my fire roasted
tomatoes gotta make sure i added my beef
again too
this is going to be another big pot full
of food
making my little spice packet thyme my
bay leaf
some rosemary i think i may have cooked
a little bit too much again
but i guess it fits the theme of a feast
now i'm going to season a little bit and
then cover it and let it simmer for
around two hours i think i'm gonna rest
a little bit now before i take on the
cheese souffle
all right so it's been a few hours my
apron
is back on and my beef ragu
is still cooking off to the side i'm
gonna take a peek
it is looking pretty good but i think it
still needs an
hour more so while that's bubbling still
i am going to get started on the cheese
souffle for my cheese souffle i'm gonna
go with this pretty big ramekin
i have some whole milk some egg whites
egg yolks that i've already separated
a little bit butter some flour and then
two types of cheese i have some parmesan
and some gruyere
first things first i'm going to grate my
cheese
i'm also just heating some milk over
here on low
heat and then now that i have my grated
parmesan
i'm just going to put it in my ramekin
coat it this is now covered in cheese
my milk has heated up so i'm just going
to remove it
i'm going to put my butter in here
wouldn't it be so nice if your tools
could just cook for you
i mean because that's what happens in
beauty and the beast right but for now
it's uh work hard eat hard i'm gonna
slowly add in my flour
add my milk and make sure it's
all combined i'm basically just cooking
it down until it becomes thick
i should have known that a feast
requires a lot of time and effort
but i have to do it this is now looking
pretty good
this is essentially a bechamel sauce and
i'm just going to flavor it
with some seasonings now i am going to
add in
my egg yolk let it cool so i can work on
the egg whites
i really hope that belle appreciated
there was this much effort that went
into her meal
[Music]
now to combine everything i do want it
to have that beautiful
top that i saw in the animation
and my cheese
into the oven cheese souffle is in the
oven beef ragu is pretty much done
so i'm going to clean up and i'm going
to cook some pasta
for the beef ragu so then the next time
you see me
i should have a beautiful spread of food
in front of me
okay you guys i didn't even have time to
take off my apron because i had to run
and get the cheese souffle but let me
can i
just show you guys this cheese souffle
it has that beautiful rise
look how jiggly it is oh my god
i think lumiere would be very proud i'm
so tired and it's slowly deflating right
now that's just what happens with
souffles but also let me show you the
ragu
i've just put it with some pasta this is
truly
the highlight of my dinner also in an
effort to make it a little more
fine dining i am also drinking some
white wine and
i totally lit a candle
to be extra like lumiere said it is
about creating
the finest experience for our guests and
i am my own guest this is
a better time than any to say bon
appetit so i'm gonna try this right now
it's cooked for hours the wine's infused
with the beef broth
the beef is like super tender now even
if it takes a lot of time
it is very worth it and i feel like all
those hours you put in you can actually
taste it in the sauce
i'm gonna cut into the cheese souffle
now oh
boy it is fluffy get out take it out
oh boy it is so fluffy oh my goodness it
is
super light on the inside i am genuinely
so excited about this it is truly
so airy like very light very fluffy but
you get like the faint taste of cheese
in there
and it's so creamy too i'm so glad i was
able
to make this finally now i can
sit down and rest i really have been
cooking
all day i am not exaggerating literally
since
bright and early in the morning to now
the sky is getting dark
eating like a disney princess is so
great the food is
amazing cooking for one really takes a
lot of time
and effort i'm really glad that i made
it to almost the end of day and i really
hope i did the recipes justice
there's still dessert coming up but for
now i am going to take a quick break
and then i can enjoy my dessert all
right this is
officially the last meal of today
i am so tired this is literally how i
feel right now
i can only keep when i open i decided to
go with the empire biscuits
from the movie brave i really wanted to
make these because i remember how
obsessed merida's brothers wear with
this biscuit they literally tried to
steal it from the lady who made it
and they would literally gobble all of
it up empire biscuits are also
a classic scottish treat so i really
wanted to give it a try so i actually
did most of the work yesterday because i
knew i'd be
super exhausted today and all i did was
pretty much combine powdered sugar
flour and egg yolk some vanilla and cold
butter
processed that and then made it into a
doll and then i chilled it
then i cut out little shapes and baked
them then i put a little bit of icing on
some of the cookies
all i have to do at this point is just
dress them up a little bit and finish it
up i actually made two sizes
one is very much thicker than the other
one i figured this one would look more
like the one
in the movie whereas normally empire
biscuits have
raspberry jam in the middle and it's
like a sandwich cookie and i really
wanted to try both versions so
i'm gonna be making both just spreading
some jam
on squish it down like so all that's
left to do
is to top it off with half of a cherry
this is my
empire biscuits if i stack it like this
it looks even more like it
this one probably looks the most like it
because of its thickness
and i deliberately kind of like made the
icing a little more messy
since that seemed to be the kind of feel
that the movie was going for
is truly just like a very buttery
shortbread
and i can totally see why merida's
brothers
would be obsessed with that feel like
you just can't go wrong with a buttery
cookie that has icing on it so yeah this
is it
made it to the very end these 24 hours
definitely felt a lot longer but with
that being said
i do kind of feel like i just like
traveled around the world
i feel like we started in like china
then we went to new orleans then i went
to france
then i went to scotland it was just
super cool testing out these recipes
from disney princesses that lived all
around the world so even though
i am pretty exhausted now it was still
very much a magical adventure so thank
you disney princesses i don't know maybe
next time i will do
a 24-hour cooking challenge based off of
pixar films
studio ghibli the possibilities are
endless so
let me know what else you might want to
see and i will see you guys next time
i'm gonna get some sleep now bye
you